Fryeburg best known building is an
imposing one Freiburg Minster the city's
Cathedral the church's spire has been
described as the most beautiful on earth
and the city wants it to stay that way
despite Allied air raids during world
war ii the tower survived the Minster is
a masterpiece of Gothic architecture
built between the 13th and 16th
centuries many of the windows date back
to that time
in the center is the striking altar by
the Renaissance painter Hans balding
green pupil of the renowned artist all
brushed durum the interior of the
cathedral is decorated with numerous
panels sculptures and other beautiful
art treasures
Freiburg is known for another notable
feature The Bachelor or little Brooks
the network of tiny streams runs for
several kilometers through the center of
town they are thought to have been built
in the Middle Ages as a source of water
for livestock Freiburg in general has a
distinctly medieval feel but despite its
appearance the Old Town is quite new
most of the original buildings were
damaged or destroyed during the war it
took the people of Freiburg decades of
painstaking work to repair and
reconstruct them an impressive testament
to that is the historic merchants hall
originally built in the 14th century and
lovingly restored
the in tomb Houghton Baron is supposedly
the oldest in Germany it's been serving
food and drinks to guests for almost
seven hundred years the menu focuses on
regional specialties
freshly sourced organic products are
very popular in freiburg the fine wines
are likewise from the bottom region in
the alta waha right next to the
cathedral everything revolves around
regional vintages with more than 300
wineries in the region with its
favorable climate modern is known as the
Burgundy paradise of Germany
on warm sunny days in freiburg people
like to sit outdoors the old town offers
many pleasant options for residents and
visitors alike
there are numerous car free zones the
city was already implementing green
principles in the early 1980s a symbol
of that is the local enthusiasm for
cycling it's the perfect way to get
around in the city and it's also ideal
for those who seek recreation in the
surrounding region
that's because there are several hundred
kilometres of bike paths in and around
the city one popular destination is the
Shou in slot a mountain in the nearby
Black Forest there is no need to take a
bike instead you can take the cable car
to an elevation of 1200 meters
once you get to the top the views are
wonderful as far as the eye can see
Sean's Londe is a big hit with winter
sports fans and with summertime hikers
and don't forget Freiburg is a gateway
to the beautiful Black Forest
you